hey
just wanna say it's uh
just wanna say a big shout out to
vaseline topolog
and thanks for his kind words yesterday
um
i've always been a big fan of vaseline
and uh
he and his friend manager silvio denial
has always been very encouraging and
positive to me all these years so
i really appreciate that and uh
it's a big honor to be playing alongside
legends such as vesseling and also bishi
anand
i think i first heard about vessel in
the
1995 olympiad
when he
i think it was i'm pretty sure it's
night 95 but his rating jumped from 2700
to
2750 and it was a
worldwide phenomenon and also he's
played tons of beautiful games
some of the most inspiring games i've
seen come from him
like
his victory over gary kasparov
linares 2005
and also his game against kasim sunop in
the same tournament
that was such a beautiful game
um also his uh his game against vladimir
kramnik
in chorus 2008 knight x7 the same is
love
it was inspiring for so many people also
many other games in the qnc indian like
against vichy
and also against pono mario were some of
the most
beautiful games i've seen
and his performance also
in the
san luis in 2005 was a big inspiration
to me
and uh yeah so
just uh
thank you bethelene and such a big honor
playing alongside